is DC's New leadership to blame or did a
behind the scenes ego Clash bury this
plant either way Black Adam vs Superman
is a cinematic Showdown you'll never see
here's why the DC Cinematic Universe is
in something of a transition period now
that James Gunn and Peter saffron have
been put in charge this has led to some
pretty big moves from within the company
such as the bombshell revelation by gun
himself that Superman actor Henry Cavill
would not be returning to the role the
drama surrounding the son of Krypton
only escalated further with Dwayne
Johnson's announcement that his Black
Adam character would not be a prominent
figure in the first chapter of Gunn and
saffron's New Vision for DC these
reveals likely shocked many DC fans
especially on the Black Adam front that
film finally released toward the end of
2022 after years in development limbo
not only that the post-credits scene for
the film for the longer waited return of
caval as Superman which seemed to hint
at a big confrontation between the two
in some future film
Black Adam
she talked however the movie was filmed
before gun and saffron took over DC
Studios and the likelihood of a showdown
between the two characters now happening
is basically zero still Johnson's plans
for the two characters were actually
quite extensive according to reports
published by variety Johnson had big
plans for his Black Adam character and
the return of Henry cavill's Superman as
many fans are likely aware already
Johnson had long been teasing some sort
of interconnecting storyline between the
two characters though it was never quite
clear exactly what those plans entail
well if this recent report is to be
believed Johnson apparently pitched the
whole idea directly to Warner Brothers
discoveries CEO David zazlov Johnson's
pitch involved the two characters
interacting in various storylines over
the coming years as a means of expanding
on their Black Adam confrontation all of
this would have eventually led to an
epic showdown between the two Powerhouse
characters this was all part of a plan
to apparently lead the DC Universe in a
New Direction at least before James Gunn
and Peter saffron became involved and
while neither DC nor Johnson have
confirmed this story it certainly Rings
true given some of his past comments
about facing off against Superman either
way it's obvious that whatever plans he
may have had aren't exactly going to
come to fruition anytime soon while it's
easy to point the finger and blame James
Gunn and Peter saffron for the scrapping
of the Pitch Black Adam Superman Saga
one has to wonder if such a plan could
have ever come together to begin with
according to variety during his time
working with Warner Brothers discovery
on Black Adam Dwayne Johnson seemed to
rub some folks the wrong way A source
told the publication Dwayne went around
everyone which didn't sit well there's
no one on this planet that can stop me
they added that many of Johnson's
demands frustrated the powers that be
one sticking point centered on the
animated movie DC League of Super Pets
which stars Johnson as a voice of crypto
the super dog he reportedly pushed for a
producer credit on the feature despite
putting in next to no effort to promote
it during its press period it has also
been claimed that he wanted a tequila
bar featuring his brand Tara a Mana at
the Black Adam Premiere even though the
film is rated PG-13 assuming all of this
is true it doesn't seem likely that the
Johnson won a partnership could have
withstood many more years of close
cooperation all in all Black Adam vs
Superman will go down as a big screen
superhero Showdown That Never Was maybe
it'll happen down the road in some form
but if you're hoping to see Dwayne
Johnson and Henry Cavill at the heart of
it well don't get your hopes up